HAVE A WONDERFUL EVENING WITH
YOUR FAMILY AND THE GREAT
SEAN HANNITY NOW.
>> Hannity: GREAT SHOW TUCKER.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WHAT DID BARACK OBAMA KNOW AND
WHEN DID HE KNOW IT?
WE WILL UNRAVEL THE BIGGEST
SCANDAL IN AMERICAN HISTORY AND
IT IS MORE CLEAR THAN EVER
BEFORE.
THAT BARACK OBAMA KNEW A LOT.
HOW MUCH?
WE WILL DIG DEEP TONIGHT AND
ALSO HOW INVOLVED WAS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IN DEEP STATES?
PROSECUTORIAL MISCONDUCT,
UNMASKING, WEAPONIZING
INTELLIGENCE ALL ROADS LEAD
RIGHT INTO HIS OVAL OFFICE.
AND BREAKING JUST MOMENTS AGO,
ACTING DNI DIRECTOR RIC GRENELL
NOW SEEKING TO DECLASSIFY IN THE
OBAMA OFFICIALS INVOLVED IN THE
ILLEGAL UNMASKING OF GENERAL
PLAN.
WE WILL EXPLAIN.
THIS IS A HUGE DEVELOPMENT.
ALSO, CHUCK TODD GOT CAUGHT RED
HANDED MANUFACTURING FAKE NEWS,
SHOCKER.
HUMPTY DUMPTY FAKE NEWS, CNN IS
HAVING A MELTDOWN AND THE
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA IS
TRYING TO STEAL OUR COVID-19
VACCINE RESEARCH.
AND 300% CHAMPION SIDEWALK WILL
LIST CAMPS.
SAN FRANCISCO IS CAUSING A
MASSIVE OUTBREAK.
NANCY, MAYBE YOU CAN BRING SOME
ICE CREAM OR BUILD A HOMELESS
SHELTER WITH ALL YOUR RICH
FRIENDS AND MULTIMILLION DOLLAR
MANSIONS AND YOUR GATED
COMMUNITY.
WE BEGAN TONIGHT WITH THE TOP
STORY AND THAT IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CALLING IT
OBAMA GATE.
AND NOW ATTORNEY SIDNEY POWELL
ACCUSING THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF
PARTICIPATING IN A PLOT TO FRAME
GENERAL PLAN.
AND TONIGHT, HUGE NEWS, ACTING
DNI DIRECTOR RIC GRENELL IS
BOWING TO DECLASSIFY THE NAMES
OF ANY OBAMA OFFICIAL INVOLVED
IN THE UNMASKING OF
LIEUTENANT GENERAL FLYNN DURING
HIS -- THIS IS A HUGE
DEVELOPMENT.
KEEP IN MIND THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION LONG ACCUSED OF
UNMASKING GENERAL PLAN IN ORDER
TO GAIN A BACKDOOR TO SPY FIRST
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND HIS
TRANSITION TEAM AND THEN LATER
HIS PRESIDENCY.
DEEP INTO HIS PRESIDENCY AG BARR
HAS SAID.
THIS COMES AS A NEWLY RELEASED
INTERVIEW TRANSCRIPTS FROM THE
INTEL COMMITTEE THAT THE
CONGENITAL LAYER ADAM SCHIFF WAS
HIDING SHOWED OBAMA HAD UNUSUAL
INTEREST IN THE CASE AGAINST
LIEUTENANT GENERAL FLYNN.
AND NOW BY JANUARY 4TH, REMEMBER
2017, ONLY A MERE 16 DAYS BEFORE
THE PRESIDENT IS INAUGURATED.
THE FBI WITH RUSSIAN COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION POUNCEY WROTE
DEROGATORY MATERIAL ON
LIEUTENANT GENERAL FLYNN.
HIS CASE WAS ALL BUT CLOSED
UNTIL FBI LEADERSHIP AND A PANIC
DEMANDED THAT THEY REOPEN IT.
ON THE VERY NEXT DAY,
JANUARY 5TH, 2017, THEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA HELD A MEETING
WITH ALL OF THE TOP INTEL AND
SECURITY OFFICIALS.
THAT WOULD BE CLAPPER, BRENNAN,
COMBING, RICE, YATES, BIDEN AND
OTHERS AND AFTER THE MEETING,
IN THE OVAL OFFICE, HE THEN TOLD
BOTH FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY
AND THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
SALLY YATES ASIDE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF DISCUSSING PLAN.
NOW WE KNOW FROM THE TESTIMONY
AT LEAST LATE LAST WEEK THAT
SALLY YATES TESTIFIED SHE WAS
SHOCKED TO LEARN THAT OBAMA HAD
COMPLETE INTIMATE KNOWLEDGE OF
FLYNN’S WIRETAPPED PHONE CALLS.
I WOULD SAY ILLEGALLY PROBABLY.
ON JANUARY 20, 2017 IN THE FINAL
HOURS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, REMEMBER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
SUSAN RICE, REMEMBER SHE WENT
BACK AND SENT HERSELF A VERY
UNUSUAL EMAIL.
WHAT IS A BLATANT CI -- CYA
MANEUVER SHE REFERENCED THE
PRESIDENT’S JANUARY 5TH MEETING
OVAL OFFICE ON JANUARY 20, 15
DAYS LATER AND SAID THAT OBAMA
SAID HE WANTED ALL OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS TO BE DONE BY THE
BOOK.
15 DAYS AGO, WHY ARE YOU WRITING
THIS ON TRUMP’S INAUGURATION
DAY?
WHY IS SUSAN RICE MEMORIALIZING
A MEETING ABOUT FLYNN IN THE
OVAL OFFICE?
DO EVERYTHING BY THE BOOK, OBAMA
SAID.
COULD IT BE MORE OBVIOUS THAT
THE PERSON THAT LIED ON SUNDAY
WITH BEN BECAUSE HE SCARED TO
DEATH THAT OBAMA’S PLOTTING AND
SCHEMING WOULD BE EXPOSED?
THE DAYS AND WEEKS TO COME, TOOK
UNUSUAL AGGRESSIVE AND FRANKLY
UNETHICAL MEASURES TO PERSECUTE
GENERAL PLAN.
33 YEAR VET KNOWING HE WAS AN
INNOCENT MAN.
COMEY, McCABE, PETER STRUCK AT
THE WHITE HOUSE DAY FOUR WITH
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION.
BY THE WAY, HE CALLED THE DEPUTY
FBI DIRECTOR McCABE AND
McCABE, HE ADVISED
GENERAL FLYNT THAT HE DID NOT
NEED A LAWYER PRESENT.
HE KNEW BETTER.
THEY SIGNIFICANTLY ALTERED HIS
ORIGINAL 302 AND WE NOW AS OF
LATE LAST WEEK HAVE THAT
EVIDENCE.
THEN THEY TURNED THE SCREWS ON
GENERAL FLYNN.
THEY THREATEN HIM WITH YEARS
BEHIND BARS AND THREATEN TO LOCK
UP HIS SON, LEGAL BILLS FORCE
THE SKY AT ONE POINT TO GO
BANKRUPT.
HE LOST HIS FAMILY HOME ALL OVER
A SIMPLE PROCESS THAT THEY
CONCLUDED NEVER TOOK PLACE.
AND YET, BY THE WAY,
PRESIDENT OBAMA IS STILL OUT FOR
BLOOD.
NOW THE INTERESTING THING IS,
BOTH SUSAN RICE AND SAMANTHA
POWERS SAID OH, YEAH, THEY WERE
SPEAKING WITH COUNTERPARTS
BEFORE THEY ENTER THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE, THE VERY THING THEY
WERE COMPLAINING GENERAL FLYNN
DATA.
A YAHOO TAPE, VERY SANCTIMONIOUS
SELF-RIGHTEOUS, ANGRY
BARACK OBAMA WAS DOWNRIGHT
APOPLECTIC THAT FLYNN WILL
LIKELY BE SPENDING YEARS BEHIND
BARS AS A CONVICTED FELON.
WE WILL EXPLAIN THE HYPOCRISY
AND DOUBLE STANDARD IN A SECOND
BUT FIRST, LISTEN TO THIS.
>> THE FACT THAT THERE IS NO
TROUBLE THAT ANYBODY CAN FIND
FOR SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN CHARGED
WITH PERJURY.
JUST GETTING OFF
SCOT-FREE.
THAT IS THE KIND OF THING
DOMINIC STUFF WHERE YOU BEGIN TO
GET WORRIED THAT
BASIC NOT JUST INTO DOMESTIC
INSTITUTIONAL NORMS, OR BASIC
UNDERSTANDING OF RULE OF LAW IS,
SPEAK TO SOMEONE CHARGED PERJURY
GETS OFF SCOT-FREE AND WRONGS
AND BREAK THE RULES, OKAY.
DESPITE WHAT YOU JUST HEARD,
BARACK PERHAPS YOU FORGOT, THERE
IS AN ACTUAL PRESIDENT FROM YOU,
ONE OF YOUR FAVORITE MILITARY
ADVISORS RETIRED GENERAL JAMES
CARTWRIGHT.
HE IS CONVICTED OF LYING TO THE
FBI, BUT GUESS WHAT, IN 2017
BARACK OBAMA IS A HYPOCRITE AND
FULL PARDON FOR HIS FAVORITE
GENERAL, THE RULE OF LAW IS IN
JEOPARDY IN OTHER WORDS GENERAL
CARTWRIGHT GOT OFF SCOT-FREE AND
HE SET THE PRECEDENT COME OBAMA
DID.
OF COURSE THE FLYNN CASE WAS
NEVER ABOUT A PROCESSED CRIME
BUT INSTEAD PART OF WHAT WAS A
LARGER PLOT TO DESTROY THE
INCOMING PRESIDENT.
LOOK AT THE TIME LINE,
AUGUST 15, 2016, PETER STRZOK
COMPARED THAT TO AN INSURANCE
POLICY IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT
THAT DONALD TRUMP WINS THE
ELECTION, SEPTEMBER 2ND 2016,
HIS LOVER LISA PAGE,
PRESIDENT OBAMA WANTS TO KNOW
EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE
DOING.
SO THAT CLEARLY STATES OBAMA NOT
ONLY APPROVED OF THE
PERSECUTION, BUT HE NOW SEEMS TO
BE ORCHESTRATING IT AND NOW THEY
ARE TRYING TO COVER THEIR TRACKS
SO AGAIN, THE QUESTION TONIGHT,
BARACK WHAT DID YOU KNOW AND
WHEN DID YOU KNOW IT?
JOE, WHAT DID YOU KNOW AND WHEN
DID YOU KNOW IT BECAUSE AT THE
TIME THE DEEP STATE WAS DOING
WAS CORRUPT TO THE CORE.
MULTIPLE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATES AND OFFICIALS WHO ARE
BEING WIRETAPPED, DESPITE
CONFIDENTIAL SOURCE OF SLIDE TO
OBTAIN FISA WARRANTS AND TOOK
AWAY THE CARTER PAGE IS, LET’S
SEE CIVIL LIBERTIES,
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
HE WAS THE SUBJECT OF FOUR
FRAUDULENT PHIS APPLICATIONS
FOUR YEARS OF HIS LIFE THAT
RELIED ON WHAT, HILLARY’S DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER WHICH WE NOW
KNOW FROM TESTIMONY THAT THEY
KNEW WAS FROM RUSSIA.
IN COMEY FBI KNEW THE MATERIAL
WAS GARBAGE AND BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR BY THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
THERE WERE WARNED REPEATEDLY
BEFORE THE PHIS APPLICATION,
DON’T TRUST STEELE, HILLARY PAID
FOR IT AND IT IS UNVERIFIED.
ACCORDING TO TRANSCRIPTS FROM
PODESTA, EVEN HILLARY CLINTON
KNEW FULL WELL THE CAMPAIGN WAS
PAYING SOMEONE TO DIG UP BRUSH
AND DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP.
LET NOT YOUR HEARTS BE TROUBLED,
THE ANSWERS NOW SEEM TO BE
FORTHCOMING THANKS TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THINGS TO
PROSECUTOR DURHAM,
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR, AN
INVESTIGATION NOW ARE MOVING
FORWARD FULL THROTTLE.
AND BY THE WAY, IT BEING
COORDINATED WITH SEVERAL U.S.
ATTORNEYS ON THIS CASE.
UNLIKE PREVIOUS
INSPECTOR GENERAL
INVESTIGATIONS, THIS ACCORDING
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR IS
NOT ABOUT A NEW REPORT.
NO, THIS IS A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AND PROSECUTION SO
HOPEFULLY WILL BE IN THE WORKS
WITH UNLIKE THESE INSPECTOR
GENERALS, THEY CAN CONVENE IN A
GRAND JURY AND THEY CAN INDICT
PEOPLE AND PROSECUTE THEM.
MANY CURRENT AND FORMER
OFFICIALS HAVE REASONS TO BE
WORRIED.
MY SOURCE WAS TELLING ME TONIGHT
SOME ARE LAWYERED UP WITH THE
BIGGEST NAMES AND MOST EXPENSIVE
LAWYERS IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
PERHAPS THEY KNOW WHAT IS
COMING.
MAYBE THAT IS WHY NEARLY 2,000
FORMER DOJ EMPLOYEES SIGNED A
LETTER BLASTING AG BARR FOR
DROPPING CHARGES AGAINST MICHAEL
FLYNN.
TIMING IS SUSPICIOUS, DON’T YOU
THINK?
LET’S SEE DEEP STATE D.C.
ELITISTS THAT ARE LOYAL TO OBAMA
AND BIDEN AND COMEY?
THE MESSAGE HAS GONE OUT TO
PROTECT YOUR OWN, PROTECT THE
DEEP STATE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE OBAMA MIGHT HAVE
BEEN SENDING OUT WARNINGS, YOU
GUYS NEED TO GO BACK TO WORK.
EITHER WAY THE PROPAGANDA
BECAUSE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
MEDIA MOB ALSO LASHING OUT AT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THIS IS NOW A PART OF THE
SYSTEMIC ATTEMPT TO DESTROY
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR FOR TRYING
TO GET TO THE TRUTH AND EXPOSE
CORRUPTION AND ABUSE OF POWER.
AND OF COURSE, THEY WERE HURTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND THEY WERE
TRYING TO UP AND A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT AFTER THEY FAILED TO
PREVENT HIM FROM GETTING
ELECTED BY PROTECTING HIS
OPPOSITION CANDIDATE.
AND ONE INSTANCE, FOR EXAMPLE
OVER THE WEEKEND NBC NEWS CAUGHT
RED HANDED DECEPTIVELY EDITING A
CLIP FEATURING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
LET’S WATCH THE END.
>> WHEN HISTORY LOOKS BACK ON
THIS DECISION, HOW DO YOU THINK
IT WILL BE WRITTEN?
>> HISTORY IS WRITTEN BY THE
WINNERS SO IT LARGELY IS
DEPENDING ON THE WRITING
HISTORY.
>> Sean: I WAS STRUCK BY THE
CITIZEN -- CYNICISM OF THE
ANSWER.
IT IS THE CORRECT ANSWER BUT HE
IS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE DID NOT MAKE THE CASE HE WAS
UPHOLDING THE RULE OF LAW.
>> Sean: ACTUALLY COME ARE
WRONG AGAIN CHUCKIE.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO CHECK THE TAPE
BEFORE YOU GO ON ONE OF YOUR
ANTI-TRUMP TYPICAL BENDERS
BECAUSE THESE WERE HIS FOUR
REMARKS AND TELL YOU, YOUR
NETWORK SELECTIVELY EDIT IT TO
SOUND LIKE SOMETHING THAT IT WAS
NOT.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
WHEN HISTORY LOOKS BACK ON THIS
DECISION, HOW DO YOU THINK IT
WILL BE WRITTEN?
>> HISTORY IS WRITTEN BY THE
WINNERS SO IT IS LARGELY
DEPENDENT ON WHO IS WRITING THE
HISTORY.
BUT I THINK A FAIR HISTORY WOULD
SAY, IT WAS A GOOD DECISION
BECAUSE IT UPHELD THE RULE OF
LAW.
IT UPHELD THE STANDARDS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> Sean: HELD THE STANDARDS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SEE
DAISY, THAT IS CALLED TEXTURE.
NBC NEWS HAD TO APOLOGIZE FOR
THE DECEPTIVE EDITING AND BIAS
BUT WILL THEY EVER APOLOGIZE FOR
CHUCKIE ABUSIVELY BIASED,
CORRUPT ANTI-TRUMP COVERAGE MASS
GRADING HIS.
CHUCK, YOU KNOW TIM RUSSERT COME
I WON’T HOLD MY BREATH.
HERE ARE A FEW EXAMPLES.
>> DO YOU THINK THERE IS BLOOD
ON THE PRESIDENT’S HANDS
CONSIDERING THE SLOW RESPONSE?
SHOW ME A PERSON WHO BELIEVES
AND NOAH’S ARK AND I WILL SHOW
YOU A TRUMP LOADER.
LOOK, THIS GETS THE
EXECUTIVE PRODUCER WOULD LIKE TO
SAY, VOTERS LIKE TO BE LIED TO.
>> I DO AND I THINK THERE IS
CONSIDERABLE EVIDENCE.
>> YOU DO?
>> FOX NEWS CONSPIRACY IS
POPPING UP HERE, I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> EXACTLY WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS UPSET AND HIS SUPPORTERS ARE
UPSET.
NEWS MEDIA.
>> IT’S NOT ABOUT THE MEDIA.
>> PLEASE!
>> Sean: THAT’S NOT EVEN THE
MOST PATHETIC COVERAGE FROM THE
WEEKEND, WHICH IS PRETTY MUCH
EVERY SECOND, MINUTE, HOUR EVERY
DAY FROM EVERY LIBERAL NEWS
OUTLET WHICH IS THE MAJORITY OF
THEM.
THIS COMES FROM PROFESSIONAL
"HANNITY" FOX NEWS STALKER, GOOD
OLD HUMPTY DUMPTY.
HUMPTY DUMPTY WAS SEETHING WITH
RAGE AT THIS NETWORK, THEY SHOW
AMONG OTHERS AND COVER THE
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER SCANDAL
IN AMERICAN HISTORY, YOU KNOW,
THE STORY THAT HUMPTY IN HIS
FAKE NEWS CNN NETWORK IGNORED.
AS THEY PUSHED FORWARD
DEMOCRATIC PARTY LIES, ONE HOAX
AFTER ANOTHER, CONSPIRACY THEORY
AFTER CONSPIRACY THEORY.
TAKE A LOOK AT HIS FAMED MORAL
OUTRAGE HERE.
>> SO THE POINT TO LOOK AT FROM
THE RIGHT WING MEDIA THESE DAYS,
THERE WAS AN OBSESSION WITH THE
DEEP STATE AND REVELATIONS ABOUT
THE RUSSIA PROBE AND THE VISIT
ABOUT MICHAEL FLYNN.
THEY ARE TREATING MICHAEL FLYNN
LIKE IT IS A BIGGER DEAL THAN
THE DEATH OF 2,000 AMERICANS
TODAY.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT CALLED INTO A
BOX AND SAID THE OTHER MORNING
FRIDAY MORNING, THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE NUMBERS CAME OUT, HE TALKED
ABOUT THE FLYNN CASE FOR
20 MINUTES BEFORE HE WAS ASKED
ABOUT THE PANDEMIC.
AND IN WHAT MIND IS IN THE
SCANDAL, ANY POLITICAL SCANDAL
COME IN A JUSTICE STORY MORE
IMPORTANT TO TALK TO THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THAN THE
PANDEMIC THAT IS RAGING?
>> Sean: THAT HUMPTY DUMPTY’S
NETWORK OBSESSED ABOUT AN ACTUAL
HOAX FOR OVER THREE YEARS,
APPLYING FOR FOUR STRAIGHT
YEARS.
BUT THEY WANT TO TELL US WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO GOVERN WHAT IS NOT.
COVID-19 THEY HAVE BEEN COVERING
FOR A LONG TIME.
EVERY SINGLE ASPECT.
HUMPTY COMMIT MIGHT BE A BIG
DEAL IF YOU RUN THE LIFE OF SOME
INNOCENT GENERAL WHO SERVED
THIS COUNTRY FOR 33 YEARS AND
YOU SET HIM UP.
AND YOU SURVEILLED THEM AND YOU
UNMASKED THEM AND RELEASED RAW
INTELLIGENCE.
I WANT TO ASK WHY OBAMA KNEW AND
WHEN HE KNEW IT.
ARE YOU REALLY THAT DUMB AS YOU
SEE, OR MAY BE WILLFULLY
COMPLICIT WITH PROPAGANDA TV OF
WHICH YOU ARE A BIG PART OF?
ME, I VOTE FOR LITERACY, ALL OF
THE ABOVE.
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED TO
FLYNN, ONE PART OF THE